while plenty of folks would argue that
Vin Diesel is one of the biggest parts
of the Fast and Furious movies most of
us would agree that it's actually the
cars cars are a big part of Fast and
Furious hence the name but we think that
the film's cars need a major change to
fit into the Disney Universe like for
starters We're not gonna have to bring
these cars to life like well the movie
Cars sure the cars in Cars don't
actually have people driving them and
that's an important part of Fast and
Furious so that complicates the
anthropomorphizing of the vehicles just
a little bit but we think the new Fast
and Furious franchise can include a bit
of buddy cop dynamic between the cars
and their drivers of course all of the
coolest cars will make an animated
appearance